[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde bienvenue dans
Camille roue libre jeudi soir à vous
raconter Florence et Marc avait pris des
cours de danse et rêver de devenir les
rois de dancefloor
a
[Musique]
c'est pas les vrais paroles non parce
que là vous dansez à fond c'est pas le
texte mais bon je reprends l'histoire
Florence et Marc avait pris des cours de
danse et rêver de devenir les rois du
dancefloor et ça tombe bien parce que
dans leur parcours de vie ils
rencontrent Pascal et Tony devrait
professionnels de la danse alors ils se
disent quoi on va aller rejoindre et
comme ça nous deviendrons les rois de la
piste et c'est ainsi qu'à l'initiative
de marque est née l'association top
dance
[Applaudissements]
et vous savez où c'est ici à Pithiviers
le vieil
et maintenant il propose quoi toutes
sortes de danse rock n' roll
[Musique]
s direct
bachata
mais toi Camille qu'est-ce que tu
proposes moi
ok d'accord si la danse des canards qui
sont au fond de la mare et après ils
font coin coin je suis désolé
[Musique]
et on va s'asseoir sur ses genoux
[Rires]
merci merci
Pascal comment la danse est venue à toi
commence à débarquer dans ta vie bah la
débarquer en allant chercher mon pain
d'accord bah oui j'ai trouvé une affiche
de cours de danse j'en ai pris pendant
6-7 ans jusqu'au jour ou un couple de
compétiteurs est venu faire une
démonstration je suis c'est comme ça
qu'on veut danser avec mon ex-mari donc
on a pris des cours particuliers pendant
un an on s'est lancé dans la compétition
et au bout de deux ans vue sur Pont de
France moi je profite de ton savoir et
de ta présence pour apprendre les
basiques avec nos chers téléspectateurs
les basiques de la salsa alors donc ça
fait 1 2 3 4 et après la même jambe et
recule
je quitte la MEC oh trop fort
[Musique]
marquer Florence comment on fait qu'on
est à pithiviers-le-vie et qu'on veut
monter une association de danse en fait
mon mari est médecin et donc dans sa
patientèle il avait quand même pas mal
de personnes qui avaient envie de faire
des choses envie de danser et puis
l'association elle a très vite grandi
avec donc quelques amis et quelques
patients aussi qui ont suivi pour se
maintenir en forme la danse c'est
important est-ce qu'on se sent mieux en
dansant tu as répondu à tout en médecine
du sport on a prouvé que la danse de
salon la danse partie c'est aussi donc
la course à pied pour le cœur et ben
voilà vous avez vu c'est le docteur Marc
a parlé voilà donc moralité ou que vous
soyez dansé vous lancez la bachata vous
lancez les danses de salon vous lancez
[Musique]
conforta